hey what's going on it's built bar and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday is it may 6 this day may 6th
I have no idea I'm here with Joe partner
Joey be what's going on now just
chilling out in Israel man it's a it's a
shame dude yeah it's like we were in
Europe for a week it's like Europe's
kind of like it's like it's like America
but it's different is who everyone is
really nice and like as we're landing I
see you guy watch your videos are like
bombs going off and anti-aircraft like
we landed we're in Israel we're in
Israel it's like dude I'll let you
explain we had that we just had the most
boss Airport experience ever oh yeah
when we landed here first of all thank
God I don't watch the news because as
always I guess things are a little what
they called it's just I see little
chippy little chicks er up yeah XAR off
sticks her up over here so yeah we got
to the airport and uh you know Wow dude
I don't know we're doing this we're
doing this like backwards we were in
[ __ ] Amsterdam the night before and
went to a bar and smoked a joint where
they also served milkshakes so I was
sitting there like I don't like I'm not
big on [ __ ] smoking weed I don't
think I do it right or I don't even
realize when I'm high or whatever
there's like this is a body high like
this just gets you [ __ ] right side
high I don't understand like dude [ __ ]
you were so high you ordered a
strawberry milkshake and then you
thought it was vanilla and then you
debated it and then you thought it was
vanilla until about halfway down you go
know it's really strawberry because it
was so subtle but the thing was white it
was the color of vanilla strawberry
shake where I'm from his [ __ ] red or
pinkish and I got the thing and I was
sipping it you know it was it was like
the the the frozen glob of it was where
all the strawberry was so when I got to
the end you know when you get to the
sort of the glacier part of the
milkshake I was like all this does have
some strawberry in it it literally did
have a flake of red in
no you know it was funny I was talking
everybody who and there was smoking and
was high and then we all got up to the
counter like we say to the lady they're
like did you charge us yet and she's
like I don't know figure it and I'm like
this is no way to run a business but the
shows have been great and Joe I got it I
gotta give you like I've never seen
anybody [ __ ] go
come over here I've seen you know a lot
of American comics I've talked to a lot
of American comics are all like are they
gonna get my stuff what do I talk about
any advice and blah blah blah blah I
remember virzi was like he was like
going like dude I know I'm gonna take a
couple of bad ones but I'm gonna figure
this out and you know he got to make
adjustments I to make adjustments you're
the only guy ever so you just came over
here and you would Joe bartnik you
walked on stage [ __ ] murdered in
Iceland Iceland Iceland Iceland and then
right through the talk just like this
guy's yeah you're as confident I'll be
over here it took me ten years to get
where the hell you're at right now so
you've been [ __ ] killing everywhere
well thank you but basically well so am
I gonna do bill I'm good I knew the
judge they got I gotta be confident with
them I know but you don't even debt you
didn't even doubt them that's amazing I
think it's a great thing I think it's
scarier to be in just like a you know in
a little club in Hollywood or like and
you know or somewhere I don't know
there's 3,000 people some of them are
gonna laugh only right your friends your
friends are the best dude how great were
they really I mean it was really great
shows yeah you know you've seen you've
seen you really loved Helsinki man that
would you spot huh Helsinki yeah you
know what's funny Oslo looks like
Pittsburgh it was funny when we're
walking through and bang the Booker
great dude was super cigars was like
they're Shandy and his buddy it worked
with them
another great duties like this is the
toughest part of Oslo it looked like it
looked like it looked like Beverly Hills
yeah it just seemed like there was a
couple of drunks it's weird you know
that Scandinavian language up there when
people do yell it it does all that [ __ ]
all saw
they can not see guard to me and like oh
[ __ ] it's starting again
but Helsinki was how stinky was awesome
I went down with a dog got up like 5:00
in the morning and walked into like a
freezing rain it really was it really
was awesome
I had a meat pie I felt like Anthony
Bourdain like Street talking to the
dockworkers that was fun
got to hang out late night in Stockholm
with some friends drink to like close
down Stockholm that was great
only rat I saw the whole time and I
literally literally a rat hotshot no
Swedish women or Tom blocked right
between her legs like nothing I just say
like yeah almost walked at the hotel
walked between and I want to be able to
handle it yeah it was pretty tough but
have fun I tell you I think Iceland was
the craziest though Iceland was nuts
there was no dogs it scared the [ __ ] out
of me
I like there's no dogs when they did
with the dogs you know I'm a dog let
I've been panting like every dog in
Europe ended last thing we're so cut too
big then I was on the Baltic Sea or the
Adrian whatever sea was freezing in
Helsinki last night
perfect weather were in Israel smoking
smoking with the biggest stick ever with
it but I don't know what that was Baltic
seas between Sweden and Finland but I
don't know what that body of water is
let me look this up here I think I got a
map here was trying to figure out all of
this [ __ ] let's see what the [ __ ] that I
just do what in God's name just happened
do you know somebody I got a Duff
McKagan it's going to be doing my
podcast which I can't believe so they
sent me a link to his new [ __ ] owl in
my suite it just never works it never
[ __ ] works
I swear computers it they like they
don't like me well we're like that last
night I would I always watch the hockey
games like out okay we're gonna watch
hockey game still work you have to redo
your password 30 times the Wi-Fi goes
nuts here so I you know it is amazing
Wi-Fi as every well that is all the
Baltic Sea says on the pump
oh we just circled the Baltic yeah we
circled the Baltic you know what I
actually we've been looking up seas
because I was claiming the Mediterranean
was the biggest and I feel the greatest
of all
the seas I like all the big Duke of the
season okay Duke haters I was gonna be
you haven't seen a game and Carolina
country uh it was neat though like well
you know like if you land like say you
fighting the Pittsburgh you'll see like
Cleveland New York Washington DC
literally when we landed Tel Aviv Tel
Aviv the cities were Beirut Cairo and
Alexandria I don't know we were like
high enough up I I think we were seeing
now when we were coming in because they
see how there's Beirut it was like how
to look at that on the map you know
[ __ ] far away yeah but there's only
so many cities they give a show you know
if you're like far enough up you see
like Dallas when you're in the middle
kind Charlie do what that one out you're
talking about when I was taking the
pictures women on final coming in no
well you know like the computers they
show you like on the screen on the on
this yeah I I don't let saying I saw a
Lebanon I thought you know what that's
what you were saying no I'm saying like
they showed you know like approaching
where you see like the screen room yeah
that was a drug battery coming in right
over like the end of iron up the most
eastern part obviously the Mediterranean
Sea and then just seeing that coast and
it's just like Jesus Christ ones were in
Israel so then we land right and the
only other person I ever saw get this
[ __ ] try so Ben Affleck was on my
flight one time right I got on the plane
he was already on the plane you know and
then when they got off and I was sitting
there going like wow this guy's just
gonna get off this guy's like a huge
huge huge star he's gonna get mobbed he
has no security person and when he got
off the plane he just went right down
with the bags where they bring like you
know that you had to check your carry-on
because there's no more over it's
basically went down that way and they
just whisked him away to this amazing
life and we got to Israel they did that
they gave us the same treatment I felt
like an [ __ ] they walked arrest
around all those people standing in line
I thought somebody was gonna say
something I throws something at us and
it was hilarious I saw this big fat
Jewish dude who I swear to God looked
like Joe DeRosa like there was something
about it
it was [ __ ] hilarious it was like
Ellis Island that we skipped yeah wasn't
even the security line it was like a
massive humanity yeah we just skipped
but we they I think we're gonna write to
the hotel like we had to go back in the
airport we just kept everybody by car
yeah we somehow went out under the
tarmac got in a car and drove to the
front of the line of immigration this
guy just walked past everybody handed
our [ __ ] all three of our passports
and they just stamped them and we walked
through it's just like what the [ __ ] was
that was the greatest thing ever so yeah
then we met the promoter and that's when
I first learned that there was some [ __ ]
going down over here he goes yeah
because I was gonna meet you here with
the bulletproof vest and I held it on
and I was like I was like oh yeah and
then he just looked me go see hey what's
been going on over here I was like no
because he was I'm sure you got a bunch
of texts I'm like no I don't watch the
news dude and he goes now you know they
see cuz they shot a couple rockets you
know in whatever form the what I don't
know how the [ __ ] it works the Gaza
Strip or something like that I read
today it was 700 but it was a big news
something have it in the Bruins game
okay how many thanks you good oh yeah
yeah so you just kept saying that I just
jokingly said dude I played Camden New
Jersey I [ __ ] survived that I think
I'll be all right yes so anyways this
place is [ __ ] magical man like I
don't think I've this is just this is
something about you know being along the
Mediterranean Sea and all that how old
this place is and all the history and
all that type of stuff and I don't know
I just hope I have a good show here
tonight there's so much [ __ ] to talk
about but let's talk about seas Joe I
had to look them up because we were like
is the Mediterranean the number the
biggest sea out here and being sports
fans there always has to be a ranking
here this is all body of water the
biggest ocean pacific then Atlantic then
Indian then the Arctic we do we see the
Arctic we worry on our knees no no no
Arctic wasn't what was on the other side
let's say we were real
hi up there hi girl hi means far up
north
yeah nobody lives higher than Santa
Claus there's the Norwegian see though
there's a Greenland see the Baron see
there's the Arctic Ocean do we want
nowhere no K I mean for Americans we
were pretty close to it yeah I didn't
realize how high up those people are
though even compared to Britain they're
pretty high up I even looked like
Iceland alright so anyways here's the
rankings of seas an ocean specific ocean
Atlantic Ocean Indian Ocean and then
Arctic Ocean coming in fourth like the
NHL against basketball football and bass
yeah it's soccer keeping up in the
battles in the oceans yeah I have no
idea Coral Sea is number one Arabian Sea
as far as size the South China Sea China
with a puck that is the Caribbean Sea
and then the Mediterranean Sea so it
ranks fifth ranks fifth but number one
in your hearts not me running with
number six in your program yeah I mean
come on today I mean out of all this
seas that you could live on long I mean
you're talking well it has the hottest
women you got you go Italy Greece France
France Spain dude how good-looking with
the people on the plight of Yeti is
really what has everything there wasn't
there wasn't like any tens but there was
no twos it was just uh you know Isabella
Czech team who's all second round drags
that wanted to prove themselves it was a
Vegas Golden Knights exactly that's
exactly what the budget anybody discard
no guys the women here or just read it
of all the cities everyone's like you
know Sweden had some hotties love sweet
assembling Finland was amazing no way
these Israeli broads their lives are
there like Wonder Woman
yeah and they know like that that
Israeli martial arts which makes them
even hotter you know oh it's a lot of
[ __ ] in a bar they can handle it well I
think they check on
like is that the waitress on the plane
how hot was she and she was like 60
years old she loved you now say
something about you Joe [ __ ] women
women love you the way they were
repulsed by me I don't know about that
I do know they come up to your energy
man they just you just smiled
you got him [ __ ] smiling they look at
me i [ __ ] weird i everybody like i
have a defensive standoffish vibe that i
wish i didn't have but you know what i
came into the world with orange hair so
i'm always looking for the other [ __ ]
shoe to drop you came in joey be looking
like a [ __ ] you know i had sideburns
when i was when i was like you know when
i was whatever like one day old i had
sideburns in 1969 and all the nurses
would always we're laughing to me my dad
would tell me like in the yeah whatever
the booth is they keep babies you had it
Joe I was forget the [ __ ] comics name
of my favorite jokes of all time he's
like some guys have dipped with women I
don't know what it is I never had it but
whatever it is I have the antidote
ladies and gentlemen anyway let's let's
start let's get into let's get let's
talk a little bit of hockey here Joe my
Boston Bruins I've missed every second
in the series being over here traveling
and my [ __ ] NHL Network speed not
working there they're up there one game
away from closing out the great team
that Columbus has put together here with
one of your favorite coaches out there
right John Tortorella the nicest thing I
can say about torts as he likes dogs I
know you just can't stand that guy
yeah it's too much stupid but he's doing
a great job right now he's doing an
absolutely fantastic job with Columbus
and you're gonna give it to Bob röszke
that goaltender you know and he's always
the regular-season guy playoffs couldn't
stop a beach ball now he's stopping
everything yeah and I got I I don't want
to Game seven with them I want to well I
think what
and this game six I'm saying obvious
[ __ ] here but I really want it I really
want to [ __ ] I just want to get past
these guys because I kind of feel like
if they get past us they might win the
Cup but he's got that we they have that
weird vibe or maybe I'm just I'm just
still so stunned that they swept Tampa
Bay who just had their [ __ ] way with
us the last two games that I watched
with Tampa I don't know like I've said a
zillion times Bobby
Tampa they just collapsed though you're
actually gonna run into a bigger bus
solve teams that believe in each other
it is the Carolina heard either next
yeah if you're worried about Columbus
Karma
storm surge is coming let me ask you
this student is it a changing of the
guard because all of a sudden it's like
all these perennial you know the very
least getting into the Western
Conference at Eastern comes finals
everybody's gone Pittsburgh gone your
Penguins gone Capitals are gone
Tampa's gone Winnipeg gone Vegas nights
I know they're not perennial but like
what they did last year they're gone the
Kings dungeon it's like it's like the
league turned upside down well a couple
things happen one a couple of some of
the fat cats just got had nothing to do
from you know st. Patrick's Day on and
lost their edge and teams had been
playing hard look at teams like the
Blues errs Carolina Columbus they all
had to win every game just to get in why
do you want to call them the Blues errs
podcast for seven years and some fun to
talk about because they've never won the
blue here's my big gripe against the st.
Louis Blues actually is they've never
won anything and they have almost as
many retired jerseys as the Montreal
Canadiens how many of these people can
actually be heroes to plague our
brothers I mean the other guy has a
thing
I gave him somebody to deal in a car now
obviously this numbers retired come on I
can see Brett Hall
I can see al McGinnis other than that I
mean really I mean right in my era I
understand I understand we say my thing
is like they never want to come there's
nothing they haven't won a Cup since
they've never want to come they've been
in the league
basically they came in the league the
year after they came in the same Ronald
was the Rana won in 67 then the next
year was the expansion they're the next
six they came in with us in Philly
nobodies yes but that was 67 68
so Maple Leafs won 66 67 and they never
won a [ __ ] cop I don't know I I just
I I don't I don't hate them I just like
calling them the Blues is fun they've
never won so they are the woods and they
kind of get a pass because American
secretaries like in st. Louis where it's
like nobody it'll have like that anger
East Coast anger and I don't really have
that hockey anger that Patrick Division
anger that Adams division anger the no
and they were in the North I will say I
never so in the media like like their GM
this year's having that has made some
lucky moves usually he's just like I
don't know I always think they're GM's
kind of a tool and they had Ken
Hitchcock who I hate Captain Kangaroo I
mean that guy I love the fact it's
Dallas and the Blues two teams that fire
can each [ __ ] I call him Captain
Kangaroo so I'm totally like they're
still in there now everyone's like oh my
god Bartek stalking Aki click no they're
actually probably upset it with me that
I haven't [ __ ] been talking it for
the longest time you know what she had
then I do my brain I don't know what's
going on my [ __ ] brain I just had
something get again something that I
wanted to [ __ ] say you said something
reminded me of something and it just
goes away Joe where does it go where
does it go in your own the last couple
years there's things sometimes I just
can't remember like you know it takes me
day I forget them every time Tracy
Morgan I love the guy one of my favorite
weeks ever worked with him there's like
a sunspot in my head that I can never
remember that I have to say
but hilarious guy said I live 30 rock to
everyone it's like I'm playing $20,000
pyramid every time I say it's so funny
like a hockey player's name so I have to
comics like that and I'm not gonna say
their names because I love both of them
but I just cannot now I have both their
names in my head right now I could say
them but I don't want to say I just for
some [ __ ] reason it just never it
never sticks it's like there's a couple
of words my whole life I just can't
spell like for the longest time I just
couldn't spell restaurant couldn't spell
it I couldn't remember it that's another
thing to do does it the older I get I'm
realizing how [ __ ] up my my brain as
far as the way I look at [ __ ] yeah you
know I always [ __ ] me up at our hotel
is when you get into a shower and you
know they have like the hot and cold and
it's done with it you know they'll have
like a red dot on the left side and then
a blue one on the right side so to me
that means if you turn it to the right
you get it's gonna be cold
right but it isn't it's it's you got to
have the whatever dot is on top
it just never [ __ ] it so I'm sitting
there you know I wanted to get hotter
and it's getting colder and colder and
I'm standing there freeze my ass up know
what the [ __ ]
so now whenever I go to a shop because I
always guessed wrong whenever I get to a
shower and I'll hotel what I do is I
just stick it in the middle for a minute
I just wait till it gets warm and then I
just turn it a little bit one way or the
other so that's the only way I can tell
when I stand in a stove to me the front
of the stove is what everybody else
considers the back I always look at it
like I'm standing at the back of a car I
don't know dude the stones now but I'll
say this a say here's the stove right
this table right here right the closest
part to me that's the back to me
front the front is like that's get it
that's the front and then we'll move in
towards the back you think you look at a
map of his show like you're buying
tickets to see without like you yeah the
front
in the back yeah that's how I look do it
like I'm standing behind a car right
yeah the thing about the showers and if
one of the only I think the only thing
that and the fact that every airplane
they have the windows up the whole time
I think the only two things I don't like
about Europe is that in the fact that
showers are all death traps
Mimi when you come to the candy I've
almost died about four times because you
guys that you big guys I haven't had a
problem with the size of it's like the
last doors that like and you have to
climb over a wall to get I think it's to
break into the shower this is a glass
door and every may hey I would do to
folks clean up but up after ugly
Americans every shower is one of those
showers it's like you could either have
the rainstorm down or that handheld you
know clean out all your crevices but
they always put the crevice thing aim
directly where your face would be when
you turn on the water like I read every
time I laugh it gets me every time
dude that's got to be that's got to be
the [ __ ] from the base yeah yeah but
I have to be honest I have no idea what
that [ __ ] handheld thing is for oh I
do but do you know it's a family show
yeah it's super clean everything out I
mean I just but you got you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] hands got to be on a washcloth
to do it and then you got that hand it's
like you're taking a hand we you got a
hands-free device where you can just
stand there cleaning yourself I thought
I always thought it was for women I
think it's like pleasure themselves in
the shower you know many ways to skin a
cat I'll tell you one thing though the
other thing I think I don't like about
Europe is a lot of and it's funny cuz I
I don't even drink soda anymore for
three years but I'm offended as an
American there's a lot of Pepsi
countries there was a lot of PepsiCo a
lot of Pepsi countries are not good
let's see come on Trump
no wait which ones where the icin was a
Pepsi country the first two were Pepsi
countries and then we seemed like we got
better than like the regular cities the
Copenhagen was a Pepsi country the
Copenhagen was the first time I smelled
urine in the street I'm like okay I'm
feeling a city now filling and filling a
city and I saw it saw the rat and Sweden
was next housenki was the Helsinki Naza
to me were the most like American cities
I'll tell you what though I love what
makes you feel at home the smell of
urine and rats no but I love the
concrete the trains the train system I
love the subways it was great Walker I
just got up every morning I walked
around here's here's this funny white
we've seen millions of people in the
streets big cities right only one person
that would kiss her kind of a jerk that
was the old guide an airport that gave
you a forum shiver oh my god
Iron Mike Sharpe and he bumped in the
candy and shooed me away like it away
yeah [ __ ] guy we were going through
airport security and I saw the stain I'm
missing my daughter and everything I
just see this guy just like lit up this
old guy with his granddaughter I'm like
god that guy totally gets it he gets
life he spoils that kid it was it was
making me feel seeing the joy that he
had with this kid made me you know feel
a little less you know [ __ ] said that
I don't know why then you know just
seeing like this scene I you know when
you're missing your kid you see somebody
who looks like they suck at being a
parent it really just [ __ ] ruined
your day but you actually see something
with that kid or grants it kid and you
see that they're enjoying it it makes
you feel I don't know you know Louis
this guy's appreciate it right so all of
a sudden like I'm going through the
[ __ ] security and I just this [ __ ]
guy like right and might like the
cross-check right in my face and my back
he said somebody get out of the way get
out way in his language and I'm looking
at like and I'm done I looked behind me
there was nobody behind me and then I
put the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
I'm looking at him it was the sweet old
guy with this kid and I'm thinking like
the [ __ ] was that about and then I just
kind of laugh because he was old and I
said to Joe I say you I go like that
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] old guy just gave me
a little mini floor I'm shiver the back
and then he can you
oh yeah yeah he [ __ ] shooed me away
he did the double head like get out of
here get out of the way yeah and then we
tell it to clubs though to Kenny and
Kenny goes yeah you pushed me too so I
think he didn't like Americans that's
the only way I can think about it
because there's one thing of being an
[ __ ] but dude you and club soda Kenny
I like you you like the [ __ ] I don't
know you both like 6-3 6-4 your [ __ ]
meatheads yeah not in the meathead sense
of like we lift we look like we're like
we lift weights but in the mean head
sense that we're just big enough in the
way no I would say meatheads okay no II
don't think the barbarians though I'm
[ __ ] with you no I know but we do
stand in the way though we're we are big
to get around well I've been doing so
well with my anger and I gotta be honest
with you that [ __ ] you were almost
triggered it almost triggered you that
set me off where I was just like I am I
really gonna am I really looking for
this guy right now the bump back in
school boy like let it go feel like they
all we see the retaliatory penalties as
well I know two minutes he red mark shot
he got in your head he got in your head
at the airport but think of all the
airports we've been in and everything
I've never been a goal scorer my team my
team can handle me in the box you know
that me fightin old guys is not gonna
hurt the pm's in your career pins oh
yeah I'm not gonna say no but somebody
else told us the [ __ ] story about I
don't know about I don't know some buddy
of his
I'm gonna make this real vague a buddy
of his that was going through some [ __ ]
with his wife whose wife who's drinking
and then she got hammered and tried to
hit him swung and missed
instead of faceplant on the sidewalk and
[ __ ] herself up and then said I can't
believe you just did that to me and was
threatening to do the old domestic
violence they do him in the level that
that [ __ ] set me off I actually
learned something about myself about
that
I kind of figured out where that came
from I kind of I grew up with a couple
of relatives that did not have good
relationships and whatever their
experience was subconsciously they put
it on me and I kind of I think I just
took that in of like Oh women [ __ ] you
over
you gave you getting you get involved
with them and then the other shoe drops
and they [ __ ] you I'm telling you Joe
it's like I join I somehow took that in
and I walk around that end with that
energy and that's why that beautiful
Israeli chick was talking to you and she
looked at me she was talking you like oh
and go see this and go see that blah
blah she looked at me she's just like is
everything all right you know well you
know was funny was like Mersey when he
wanted the person to call him mr. versi
I'm like Oh is she gonna tell me the
places to go one of the funniest things
ever in first class cuz he was so into
mr. amenities whenever she goes to can
teach and she gave Kenny's last name mr.
and then she's like mr. burr name is mr.
Bartnik and then she started talking to
me since he's getting some birds you
like what do you want
can you please call him mr. versi Mersey
fly together we laughed the whole time
we look like two homos going on under
honeymoon you see you two guys together
like you know what it can't happen for
me it really happen for me so who's your
pick who's your pick to go to the
Stanley Cup sharks Bruins sharks Brumath
or jumbo joe coming back maybe hoisting
the cup in Beantown but yeah
I had I to be I had to get another great
player that we shipped out during that
time because he you know that told he's
not a Bruin it's just like but what the
[ __ ] does that mean
he's scoring goals by the goddamn bagful
I don't know I never understood that one
they always you know what it was you
know the Flyers did that thing for the
longest [ __ ] time or they still do
know that no they don't they don't but
they they did the how they wanted in
standing for seventy five they kept
playing that way it was like they kept
at high school jacket on like the next
[ __ ] thirty years the Bailey's the
Bruins also had that big bad Bruin we
play this we play a certain style so
when we would get guys that came in who
were big guys who weren't going to sit
in the penalty box and they were just
going to score [ __ ] goals I don't
think we knew how to deal with them or
at least Harry Sinden didn't way back in
the day it wasn't the worst trade though
for both parties concerned but yeah I
had the Bruins I thought I thought
Bruins had the best chance of beating
Tampa Bay and I was wrong about that
Columbus did but I I think this is the
Sharks year I think they all know that
they had the bright blend of youth and
they got Karlsson on the blue and blue
line now I mean they they think they can
control 45 minutes with two two
defenseman between Birds well what about
the Boston Slam for the boss in the slam
just because of all the people that just
hate Boston I think it's I think
jealousy and envy is just the worst
thing on earth when people are jealous
people or amuse people it's sickening
so see how jealous and envious the way
that woman was talking to you and why
she'd blow by makeup I hope you didn't
look across the aisle what was so funny
was I think we have to tell the story we
have to tell the story of the family
orgy you know a family pool with the
Holiday Inn and then at the hotel oh
well
where were we we were in Amsterdam that
was Amsterdam but they had the [ __ ] they
of this great gym downstairs spiral
staircase down and they had this this
pool at the spa and I brought my I
finally member to bring my bathing suit
and my swimming goggles I've been
swimming laps every city I've been going
to thank God we like Thornton Mellon
talking about what's going on in your
life like it's okay bill a couple more
laps
Steve so we going to [ __ ] the steam
room right and I'm thinking you know
there's a men's one and a woman's one or
whatever and I forgot how close to
Germany we were what dude I'm telling
you a [ __ ] butt ass naked we got
there and it was like a co-ed one so we
get in there and we [ __ ] walk in and
I look into like the the sauna and it
looked like The Partridge Family it was
like an entire family in there there was
like men women kids all different ages
and like just the lie I looked for two
seconds and I was look look I saw a lot
of skin and I just started laughing and
I turn around I walked out I had to
regroup and be like I'm not [ __ ]
going in there so then I saw the same
room so we went in there and we got in
there and they had that thing turned
onto about like 72 degrees or something
it wasn't even hot and I'm it was it was
it was not as hot as your grandmother's
house yeah it was it was [ __ ]
horrific and then you told me I said
dude I couldn't look into that sauna
room and you were like yeah there's a
couple of women in there with their
beavers out I was just like I'm not I'm
not [ __ ] going in there I'm not
[ __ ] refused to do that so then those
those those little Italian kids came in
it was like growing up Gotti there is
Italian kids in there spraying the room
with hoses or just spraying each other
by himself yeah yeah it was it was it
was funny how you said it though it was
like we went from like the Holiday Inn
and you know Cincinnati family pool -
like we joined the cult in Germany
that door yeah like the pool then the
pool is there was a bunch of kids in it
was this amazing pool and we were
spoiled because there's been nothing but
like lap pools for adults we got there
yeah I was like the [ __ ] way back I
got we've sent in a Howard Johnson
[ __ ] I don't know that one they used
to have we could drive down the Cape
when I was a kid but anyway so I end up
going upstairs and I just [ __ ] worked
out instead but dude I got to tell you
right now
that [ __ ] [ __ ] when you go into a
sauna then there's men and women there
and everybody is [ __ ] naked it's like
they're you know go join a cult go
[ __ ] go to one of those this like I
don't understand how it's like we're in
a regular part of town and all of a
sudden I go to like a nudist beach like
that's more like a specific kind of
[ __ ] person there was one in San
Francisco it's hilarious you know the
Baker beach so I was screwing around so
I'm like oh my god I'm gonna show up and
mess with my girlfriend who's not my
wife and be naked you know she's my
buddy Kathy Kevin get this closing we're
walking down and all of a sudden it's
like she's with a bunch of people we
work with
I drank a lot more well not a lot more
but more yeah it just it was it was just
you know there's no there was no reason
for her to the women to just be like
spread-eagle it was like they could've
just sad there nicely like that the
robes on like I did then you go in there
and then there's like this pressure
because they're naked if you don't get
naked then you're a [ __ ] weirdo and
it's like no I'm the sane one here yeah
no I kept I kept it together I don't
know maybe I don't maybe it's my [ __ ]
uptight Catholic upbringing let me read
a little bit of advertising here
all right policy genius it's spraying
exclamation point the time of year when
seeds grow into flowers Oh does that
still actually happen I thought
corporations owned all the [ __ ] seats
and you grow up financially at least
your family needs protection if
something happens to you and then
means you need life insurance this is
the Dave Semenko a [ __ ] are they
going to protect you here thankfully
policy genius makes it easy to get that
financial security without the growing
plant pace policy genius is the easy way
to buy life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle the paperwork at red tape no
Commission's no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of mind
no strings attached the policy genius
doesn't just simp simple buy life
insurance they also make it easy to
compare and buy home insurance auto
insurance and disability insurance so
next time you stop to smell the roses
pull out your phone and head to policy
genius calm policy genius spring is here
kick it off by nipping life insurance in
the bud
it is the bud bu D do you have insurance
life I got all that [ __ ] I got nothing I
got all that [ __ ] like I have car
insurance
we got conscious we got something yeah
well I guess I got car again and you got
a great like Carl's the car is i owns
much more valuable than me well maybe
you should go to policy genius income I
think I'm going to do all the compares
compare some prices and you know what
your wife's going to be so happy that
you did that she's going to get you some
sherry berries oh it's a [ __ ] segue
Mother's Day is coming up and it's
absolutely nothing most of us wouldn't
do to make sure the special moms in our
life are happy I love how they clarified
that so dysfunctional people wouldn't
get offended hate my mom she took your
[ __ ] talk about your mom and why she
deserves to be happy this Mother's Day
because she's my mom like why do I have
to get into they poo hate their moms I
just don't I mean you know well I mean
you could have an [ __ ] mother yeah
everyone's mom's nuts like you know and
Vimal ang is nuts
she's like ray Romano's mom funny but
then there's women who [ __ ] put their
kids in scalding bath water I mean come
on come on yeah
have to make me say that the middle of
this Reno I melted the chocolate off
this Friday
yeah I don't even have to go that
extreme well I danced around it you
weren't taking the bait like everybody's
Ron's crazy you're making like the ones
who like make jello with the fruit in it
no I'm going a minute further than that
all right Sheree's berries has special
Mother's Day berries designed from just
moms they're topped with chocolate chips
pink shimmer sugar and swizzles describe
how much these gourmet goodies would
make the special mom and your life smile
well not my mom she probably would say
she could make it better but excuse your
delivery date to ensure mom gets your
gifts of Sherry's berry exactly when you
wanted to and your satisfaction is
always guaranteed don't wait until the
last Bachelor wouldn't do that she would
try to figure out how you make him and
then she would make them better don't
wait until the last minute on this one
visit berries calm today to order
freshly dipped strawberries starting in
1999 for the moms in your life to make
mom really happy you can double the
berries for just $10 more Mother's Day
is Sunday May 12 so visit berries calm
that's B e RR IES calm click on the
microphone and then I upper right hand
corner and enter my code BRR that's
berries calm click the microphone code
BRR cherries berries do kick-ass they do
I got to say and for the record my mom
yes she's like fun kind of crazy oh yeah
she's royal you're right crazy she's one
of those my mom is actually totally sane
my mom my mother is a saint yeah I've
always told her if your mom's mellow
yeah she's in she's in the HOV Lane
she's in the express lane to go to
heaven
Stan's calm me I'm in the breakdown lane
Oh
Sam's calm no one really has time to go
to the post office you're busy who's got
time for all that traffic parking
lugging all your mail and packages it's
a real hassle man
that's why you need stamps come one the
most popular time-saving tools for small
businesses stamps comm eliminates trips
to the post office and saves you money
with discounts that you can't even get
at the post office with Sam Sarkar so a
jet lag you get five cents off every
class first class stamp then up to 40%
off Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost for those expensive
postage meters stamps comm is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps come right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage at a digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bird
that stamps comm enter ber all right how
do you get five cents off of a stamp
well I mean they cost more than five
cents so there you go it seems like a
good deal though it is especially you
know that makes me want to write more
people yeah I'm gonna put softer stuff
you know yeah you have to have to make
sure that my stuff gets there it's like
I think I never use again I only once in
my life I put a check into an ATM
I like seeing somebody's face oh yeah
you're one of those guys well that's
good I mean it kind of kills the copy I
just read that no no I'm gonna say no
I've said it's a great deal all right
by the way my patreon page I had to shut
it down because for those who follow me
on Instagram I'm just I just don't
[ __ ] I'm not I just walk around I'm
not what am i a [ __ ] working for Meet
the Press or whatever somebody some
gumshoe with some [ __ ] I'm not filming
the [ __ ] I'm doing I'm doing this [ __ ]
I'm doing so I suck at it
and I felt bad like I was taking some
people's money I just don't want to
[ __ ] do it anymore so we're gonna we
got a YouTube all the uninformed are now
going to be available on I to
Google Play Spotify you can catch up now
new episodes to come me and Joe DeRosa I
apologize to people that subscribe to my
page
I started off fast I had a couple of
helicopter videos and just I just never
I just never think to do that I saw a
[ __ ] JetBlue plane that they people
thought they were going to crash and
people had the presence of mind during
possibly the end of their life just I
loved it started filming like their
phones were gonna survive you [ __ ]
drop your phone off a goddamn table with
no [ __ ] case their screens shatters
you're gonna survive them you you're
gonna die but there's gonna be a plane
crash and your [ __ ] phone's gonna
have the video yeah no patreon just
seems like way too much work to keep up
the content I don't know what to give
and what to pay for I mean I mean I'm
not saying I'm saying what to do one
myself we were gonna do one for pop it's
like when someone gets a free t-shirt
what else is there looking at walking
around then if I put my morning skates
on there and it's like then people who
just want to see it for free I just like
you know like you've gotta give them
back hey you're a man of the people do
you think that if this is a part of it
that's comforting
you know when you're in a near-death
experience to film it because now it
feels like you're so excited about the
content you're gonna have for your
Instagram that it takes you out of the
fact that you could pass it
that you're not going to be around to
upload it but you're going to be
immortal everybody's gonna be like epic
guys films his own death I don't know
Joe I'm just trying to learn relate to
the youth here let's let me let me read
some of the I'm sorry there's a couple
here job that I I'm gonna start with
this one because there's no this is this
is male time this is male time I went I
just wanna say one thing that I thought
was interesting if you don't mind I
thought you can chime in whenever you
want no because I said hey because I
didn't know if we were gonna be an app I
didn't know visuals like considered
Africa that I would knock off five
continents I've been to know it's Asia
they it right so they told me that it's
Asia but they pretend
but they're in Europe saying they
identify so I was saying so they're like
transgender in the sense that they even
though they are Asian they identify as
Europeans yeah that's that gets in all
that race [ __ ] like white people I know
it's weird it's weird it's almost like
how real estate you know they do that
and they try to act like you know yeah
it really is Harlem but they call it
something else
yeah because they don't want to scare
white people or whatever like Asia's
this [ __ ]
okay one of the greatest things I ever
did was that time when I did that
Singapore Hong Kong Mumbai there great
[ __ ] people so if you're in Asia I
don't know why the [ __ ] you wouldn't
want to say that your agent that's weird
to me alright resident Scientologists
hey Billy orange balls see the lack of
respect that get him been a big fan for
years loved all your specials this new
podcast but I grew up a Scientologist oh
I know Bill I mean it's really
Scientology how do you do that I thought
they were gay who Scientologist damn you
you thought Scientologists were gay
nothing to take the closet really I mean
I know to remote that has kids but other
than that like I mean well it's not
everybody I don't know I think it's just
like this cult well this is the thing
Christianity is a cult they always
energizer yet they think well what
happens is you get big enough that then
you're not a cult you're just considered
a religion so I think like that's that's
what Scientology is working towards is
getting rid of the cult status just like
us as comics they're working their way
it's that they're going up you know I
would say Scientology right now this
selling out improves and they want to
become a theater act like you know
Christianity I feel like you that cat
the Catholicism used to be an arena act
and now they're back down to theatres
with after they got cut [ __ ] all
those kids I don't know to thought
system is like there
like their big dude now dude it's dying
in our country and so now they're going
down to South America watch out
everybody in South America don't buy
into it no I mean I know I knew that I
didn't I know you could grow I mean
really there's like families are just
we're Scientologists beyond that that's
just with adults joined that's all I
guess no but I got it both your parents
or Scientologists then yeah okay
they've been around long I'm sorry it's
yeah I don't know it's not ignorant not
just gay people that joined a week it is
it's not just guys that it's not just
guys that like wanted to move up in
Hollywood it's not like right you know
what it's just you have a you have a
very Hollywood la experience with it so
there was yeah there was a lot of that
it seems like in Hollywood it's like if
I wasn't gay and I don't want to do
rehab then I'll become a Scientologist
it's gonna make the next level of -
sneak in the back door of to get a
career going yeah I don't know I'm
whatever I look at all religions is the
same where it works be god bless you but
I think it's all [ __ ] me too I look
at the same exact way all right growing
up as a Scientologist I was looked at
weird yelled at in the streets
brainwashed yeah you name it
brainwash as we sit there talking about
all of our [ __ ] [ __ ] I heard
everything I never understood it what
the [ __ ] why though then one day it
happened I looked at myself in the
mirror I had a huge piece of lettuce in
my teeth
all those years embarrassing a guy says
he's saying metaphorically every
comedian who brings up Scientology and
their jokes including you says how crazy
we are I never said you guys were crazy
I compared you I said you were as crazy
as my religion I thought I showed
respect when I said you were nuts right
I don't know I'm trying to make myself
to hear and how crazy religion is but I
don't believe that that's what you've
got what you guys think because if you
actually thought we believed in the
aliens coming down and the spaceships
and the mind-reading
I never said mind-reading I didn't know
he was assigned coaching mysteries he
we're like a
Battlefield Earth t-shirt probably told
them well up because if you actually
thought we believed in the aliens coming
down and the spaceships and the
mind-reading you'd all be on [ __ ]
board every one of you no I wouldn't
this maps all caps accent Cooley should
ever do that's the cool [ __ ] ever if
you're smoking weed talking about it but
if it's an actual organization and
there's some old crusty redheaded guy
telling me this [ __ ] yeah I'm [ __ ] by
your other watch Barney's TV in
Amsterdam then spaceship so I don't buy
it anyway says I laugh when people say
Scientology is crazy and bad and wrong
and their only source of information on
the subject is anti Scientologists who
hate Scientology I saw the Scientology
documentary stay away I mean it's a
decent point he's making it if you
thought that documentary was good you
would love the documentary Hitler did on
the Jews amazing best ever or that
documentary the wily coyote did on the
roadrunner oh man stay away from the
roadrunner most horrible bird of all
time alright so this guy's obviously
offended and does not have any sense of
humor about dude you can say whatever
you want about the Catholic Church I
mean we literally tortured people into
becoming there's a torture chamber in
this hotel eight hundred years old yeah
they'd hire a torture chamber that they
used to put on religious yeah dude that
creeped me out and go see that in the
end of one of the little iron [ __ ]
things that you would put the chain
around a little hoop in the wall I was
just like dude I want to be down here
this is like my entertainment and other
people get you know and it was part of
the crusade they were [ __ ] torturing
people dude this is the thing uh you can
say whatever you [ __ ] like it want
about my religion and I'm not saying
that there isn't something after this
and spirituality and all that [ __ ]
but religion is it's a [ __ ] business
and it's in and I I believe that would
mine I don't know enough about yours and
just out of respect that your religion
is your religion I'm not going to say
anything about it but like it's pretty
much I
it's not if it works but you got blessed
it's all organized crime all right most
people who are nervous or put off by
Scientology have never read any
Scientology books I dub these people
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] scared little little
men well I mean you sounded like a crazy
person why do I want to read a book now
you just sound dumb about Scientology
though it's like you know have other
things to do with my life it's like what
I want to do that I will say this one
time somebody recommended an acting
class it was the weirdest [ __ ] thing
I ever been in all right dude you know
what now I'm gonna tell this [ __ ]
story because now you're going a little
too hard here because I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell you this I so many like long
long time ago we're talking billboard
with [ __ ] full head of hair
long time ago said to me hey because I
was looking to take an acting class
because I didn't have an acting gig nor
anything like that you know I was out in
LA you know it's what you do I you need
to get on TV and whatever dumb reason
right so this person recommended this
acting class so I go in you know acting
class you know it's pretty packed too
right so and there's a guy teaching it
he's famous all right I'll tell you
after the podcast who it was so I'm like
wow this revolta wouldn't bleep us huh
it was Travolta blink twice but no no he
was that time he's too busy crushing it
and so I [ __ ] go in there and they go
okay and the guy goes to start the class
he goes okay does anybody have any news
they want to announce and some of the
class raises their hand they're like
yeah I just booked two episodes on jag
like it's not a long time ago dude and
when I tell you the whole class like you
would have thought somebody just [ __ ]
hit a three-pointer to win an NBA
championship they all just going like
[ __ ] crazy and I was just like dude
what the [ __ ]
three other people announced I got
something on friends are [ __ ]
Everybody Loves Raymond screaming like
that so then they go all right ladies we
have a couple of people auditing the
class today they go we got police wise a
stand-up comedian please welcome bill
dude and they cheered that loud again
like my face turned red it was [ __ ]
like [ __ ] crazy and I'm like what the
[ __ ]
so during the the break of the class I
go in to meet them to talk to him I'm
auditing the class is what they call it
you check it out
and the guy's just going like you know
we have our own security we have our own
everything was our own blah blah and I
jokingly said Jesus Christ I feel like
I'm joining a cult and he sort of looked
at me it was I was like what the
you know so whatever so I end up Lee and
I talked to the guy during the break the
famous dude he's just looking he goes
was that a little much in the beginning
was it a little much and I was looking
at was like it was pretty intense dude
so I ended up leaving and I did I told
this story to somebody they were
laughing they go where did you go and I
told them and they go pill that's
Scientology I go get the [ __ ] out of
here
and then these [ __ ] creeps for like a
week kept calling me thank you dude it
was freaking me out like they was
stalking who the [ __ ] was supposed to be
an acting class and these [ __ ] guys
wouldn't leave me alone I finally had to
get like firm with them and be like dude
I'm not going back and the guy goes we
lost you yeah dude so [ __ ] you man [ __ ]
you like dude I didn't take something
like they I was like legit uncomfortable
like I got to the point like I felt like
I'm like these [ __ ] follow me
around yeah like in San Francisco they'd
have chicks to go hey I'm gonna take a
personality test I'll go sit in a booth
with you for 20 minutes and then all of
a sudden it's like and they try to
become Scientologists but I don't know
why like I don't know but I like reading
books but it's like it's like why don't
you read a book it's like why don't why
do I want to read a book about that [ __ ]
listen here's the thing Joe having said
all that what they do and that is way
less than the Inquisition or any of that
other [ __ ] however it's still all
unacceptable [ __ ] behavior as far as
I'm concerned and I'm entitled to bet so
dude I respect the fact that you're a
Scientologist you want to do that [ __ ]
god bless your people you want to go to
[ __ ] church people over here whatever
the [ __ ] you guys want to do I don't
give a [ __ ] just I just just respect me
that
I don't I don't I don't want to I don't
want to be a part of it I just don't
want to be a part of it I just want to
be a [ __ ] you know my new religion is
right now Joe the new Queer Eye for the
straight guy on Netflix because they've
now taken it to the point that they
don't just you know find straight guys
that dress like us try and help us out
they actually help people's lives like I
saw me helped out these two sweet older
women that they were running their dad's
barbecue joint in [ __ ] Kansas City
not only did they do a makeover their
clothes they got their teeth fix they
got their hair done
then they [ __ ] redid their whole
barbecue place without ruining it they
just updated it and then they also got
their secret barbecue sauce think they
found a factory down the street that
would jar it they could sell it so it's
like good so it's like Bar rescue and
Queer Eye for the straight guy yeah but
you know when I watch bar rescue
there's something about when they go in
there they're just gagging because those
people are like morons these people just
like needed help I don't know everybody
bar seemed like a better place to drink
before Taffer gets there yeah three
drinks and chicks taking up the clothes
the attacker shows up is like yeah I
don't need a mint julep yeah like that
broad top was giving me a plan you give
me a shot of beer well I just watched
one episode of that quitting the nuke
where I they can't just say why watch it
with me when we were in Iceland it
literally made me want to be a better
person like I'd like all we do is [ __ ]
about rich people and [ __ ]
politicians and all of this [ __ ]
religion and all that and like meanwhile
we could all be helping each other out
on the bottom and then then [ __ ] all
these people it's just like and maybe I
don't know what I'm gonna do probably
nothing because I'm a selfish [ __ ] but
it'd make you know it's such a good show
it made me think of being about it being
a good person right that's that's a step
just first start to start yeah I was
gonna start singing that Michael Jackson
song I'm stopped by it's a bad time to
do that all right the man in the mirror
okay all dead hey Billy billionaire give
him seven seventy percent
I don't even know what that means like
because I was bitching that you know
they should look at the 20 trillion
untaxed US dollars in the [ __ ]
Caribbean rather than [ __ ] going
after newly rich [ __ ] college kids
who invented an app and had the audacity
to be worth more than 10 million bucks
my boyfriend and I have been together
nearly four years and the baby talk is
starting to get more serious on his part
though I've never really wanted children
in fact I hate most it's but I am
someone open to the idea
oh geez you're all over the road here
the problem is that he is 46 and I am 28
well yeah that was going to be a problem
these balls are drying up over there I
can see myself wanting a kid later maybe
in five to ten years but with him being
so old I'm not sure we have that kind of
time though you talk about being an old
dad all the time in the podcast and well
it's funny I can see where it's also
terrifying
yeah like am I going to die before I get
this bird flying here by the way good on
you for getting fit and healthy we
started going to the gym and eating
healthy a few years ago our only problem
is a little weekend binge drinking
he also hits the adderall hard at those
times oh boy
obviously that panics me when
considering having children other than
that we make a small team we split bills
travel and have individual hobbies
somehow the age different hasn't been a
problem except with the baby talk should
I pull back on the fear and go for it
try to wait until I feel ready which
could be never telling to adopt another
dog thanks in advance and if they try to
take 70% bite them to the death Cheers
bill all right my opinion on this and
you don't want to get you don't want to
hear my opinion let's say you don't have
a kid you're gonna ruin your life
she needs a kid he can find somebody
else you're 28
you got another 10 years you love travel
you love this you love that it changes
everything if you're not ready to have a
kid do not bring a kid into this world
yeah III
look at it like if you love this guy you
know I don't know I've seen nothing not
it's been nothing but positive having a
kid for myself I'm not saying you're not
saying it's not positive but if you're
not on the same page that's kind of a
big thing and that guy doesn't have a
lot of time I don't know I guess Tony
Randall and Mick Jagger had one of their
70s so let me not together I mean I love
my daughter everything but your life
changes and it seems to me that you're
still young yeah and you want in you're
traveling and you're doing this and
you're doing that and it's like that
ends I but I also look at like twenty
eighths a great age to have a [ __ ]
kid I mean you can use I mean I'm asked
you kid [ __ ] graduates College right
around the time you're 50 then you're
going to get to be a grandmother or a
grandfather you get to see that you get
the [ __ ] and get people forearm shivers
and they don't do what do you think in
the [ __ ] Airport there's this listen
this biz like any big decisions there's
this like you know this ups and downs
dad except just get a kidney
old-fashioned way [ __ ] around if you get
pregnant it's a miracle if you don't you
don't all right worst advice ever
I advise don't listen to either one of
us alright need some advice buddy Billy
baldness I love you podcast expensive
over I thank you but ask us kissing
aside I'm in some [ __ ] so I've been
dating this girl for almost two years
now and everything has been great up
until about four months ago she is
non-binary what does that mean that's
that's above my pay grade hang on a
second I gotta look that up that's one
of them codes for like gay but not gay
or whatever yeah that's one of those
ones who take dresses up differently but
means to be somebody else but I thought
what's a genderqueer Wikipedia what is
not by a nun non-binary gender is an
umbrella term to describe any general
identity that does not fit into the
gender binary of male or female
like I said my city no I try to do the
math on that so yeah I'm not good at
algebra either wait I mean I need my
daughter's math tutor to do it I don't
give a [ __ ] if I'm looking up [ __ ] like
this or just a definition of a word then
there's always like another 20 things
you have to look up dude I looked up
this stupid Patriots Mitchell & s coat
like [ __ ] full months ago they won't
leave me alone I'm not buying it
flopping up with the ads give up after
you Google non-gender by Nick maybe
maybe he doesn't want a Patriots jacket
all right now you way to get the muffler
trail non-binary gender is an umbrella
term described and identity is not fit
into any gender barnett male appeal
non-binary gender also sometimes
referred to as genderqueer people may
for exists and genderqueer I thought
queer was offensive but if it's part of
a bigger word it isn't
for example identify identifying as
having no gender fall on a gender
spectrum somewhere between male and
female or identity okay alright I think
I get that now that just means like
people look at you - look at you naked
you're a dude but you don't feel like a
dude right oh Lord I know we could never
think we could never sound dumber right
now let's just be this Isis he's
non-binary so she has no real sexual
preference and she's had had a female
friend that she dated in high school
does that mean they said why did he just
say she's cool I like not binary chicks
a new word you learn something every day
I look at that chick
drugs so she is non-binary [ __ ] has no
real sexual pressure she's had a female
friend that she dated in high school
and it was on and off from what I
understand but this person moved to
California years ago and moved back to
our state like six months ago and that's
when the problem starts I had no issue
with it dude you gotta somehow know you
got to get in there you got to get it I
had no issue with it until recently when
my girlfriend asked me if I would mind
if she got a girlfriend but I'm not cool
with that we talked somewhat about it
and she gets irate every time we talked
last night she you wrote cute she cut
basically all her hair off and all I can
see is get friend now what dude this is
like the most important part of the
sentence on top of that she's been
posting non-stop about gay stuff
normally I wouldn't care but they also
snapchat each other at all times of the
day and she's gotten very private about
her phone I mean Jesus Christ it every
more red flag see me which lends me that
she walking over the t-shirt that said
not failing dick right now I mean it's
yeah she's this is a wrap dude
which leads me to believe some [ __ ] is
going town she says she doesn't want to
leave me but also won't budge with my
requests on them taking less on changing
platforms listen dude what's going on
here is because she doesn't identify is
she's kind of leapfrogging over with
political correctness that she's going
to go [ __ ] and have sex with somebody
else when she's is she in a committed
relationship but you have an open
relationship then I guess you'd have to
roll with this but if you guys are in a
committed relationship if she goes out
and gets with a guy or a woman that's
not cool
like dude you got it like I would get
out of this she buddy she invited him in
though
wait he's the one that said no wait well
I missed that part
well I think up there similar
so I mean every Santa Claus lives he's
non-binary and she's had a female friend
of Ivana on and off but this person
moved to California I had no issue with
this until recent my girlfriend asked me
if I would mind if she got a girlfriend
that that will ice like him well am I
going I might be gonna be part of that
okay excuse me I was wrong I thought you
said that she's a chump don't let your
fantasy get in the way of what these
people actually say and also right also
to throw a wrench in everything we have
we have an apartment together and we are
both on the lease I'm kind of [ __ ]
because I have no family out here and
just one friend I initially moved out
here for but he got a lady and turned
his back on me about a year ago what you
got a lady to do what are you talking
about any advice please keep up the
content my bald brother all right this
is what I would do dude like yeah I
would just get out of this [ __ ] thing
and you're both on the leash so you know
she wants to have a new girlfriend over
letter who gives a [ __ ] and this is the
thing dude I would break her I break up
with her and then just be just be
[ __ ] cool all right don't get
involved in I'm but then you know what's
going to happen is they going to want
you to get the [ __ ] out of there but I
would actually work on my life more he
can't tell me whatever the [ __ ] you live
in there's not a place that you can find
on your own you know what I would do it
the way she just said [ __ ] this I'm
getting a girlfriend and cut her hair
she's just doing what the [ __ ] she wants
to do then I would be like mine what I
would do I go I would go al Madrigal
well al just gets the whole bucket thing
done and then just hands him a box full
of stuff and B here's your stuff were
broken up I would go [ __ ] get another
apartment all right and one day while
she's at work I take a day off from work
I get a buddy I'd move all my [ __ ] out
and then that would be it and then I'd
call it say listen we need to talk and
she's gonna come home and be like
where's all your stuff I said moved into
an apartment because we're breaking up
and then she's going to get mad she's
going to say you're a coward you're a
[ __ ] that's me like no no no I'm not
going to [ __ ] stay here while you
mentally [ __ ]
torture me okay you're doing what the
[ __ ] you want to do you know so that's
good advice
yeah I'm doing what the [ __ ] needs to
get out because she obviously is saying
we're done yeah and I think that she's
leaning I mean what I can't get not not
the gay part of it what I can't get past
is that you're in a [ __ ] relationship
and she's gonna start banging somebody
else like yeah this is what the [ __ ] I'm
doing if you were to say that I'm gonna
start banging another woman is it okay
if I get a girlfriend I don't think
she'd be cool with that so I mean I
don't know all the parameters of that
but like you know if you're with a woman
if she starts banging another woman or a
man that I don't know whether your
relationship is at that point if she
didn't invite you in your she's
basically cheating on you to your face
yeah but just because you asked is that
is that I wanna try that with my wife is
it alright if I get a girlfriend in the
Sun all right sex with my favorite very
binary yeah yeah oh my god what if I use
binary if I say binary and then I just
get my new girlfriend address like a
dude said then do I did on like a
technicality this woman was my wife owe
me an apology like I bang the new chick
alright sex with my wife so I am 36
years old and I had been with my wife
since I was 19 my wife is one year
younger than me okay so she's 35 we have
three children 1510 and three I mean
okay this guy's gonna be a great
grandfather I'm jealous we only have sex
on average about twice a month dude
that's amazing
if you have three [ __ ] kids you've
been together that long yeah this guy's
doing great he's killing it he's killing
it it's been like this on and off since
we had kids I am at to the point now
where I don't even make a move I can't
stand the rejection so I ought to
toughen the [ __ ] up man you got to see
them you got to see the funny
the hilariousness in it and then the
patheticness when you just grab your
laptop and go once and porn Hey welcome
to the fraternity so I just wait until
she makes the move but I get in a very
bad
mood after a week without sex now Jesus
made it the man has no hands yeah rub
one out and bring it from one out go
smoke a cigar she will ask what's wrong
I just replied nothing well that's your
fault you got to communicate we have a
very good relationship with the
exception of sex I get to a point where
I'm actually thinking of leaving her
over this but I love my children what
should I do
all right you're not gonna leave here's
the deal you have to just you got to
tell her how important sex is all right
and you got to tell her that you get the
bad mood she's not taking carry on some
level but this is one of these things
with these modern-day women where it's
just like you know if they're not
getting what they need they can tell you
that you have to do all of these [ __ ]
things but you know if if you're like I
don't know if you ask them to do
anything that's considered you know
taking care of you nowadays like I won't
even bother with this conversation
ya know but you know as sad as sad as a
mediocre [ __ ] could be sometimes
that's all you need doesn't have to be
this extravagance maybe maybe once or
twice more months she could pop in the
quick 10-minute Andy you know I can't
tell you though you can't try to get her
motor running though yeah yeah sometimes
women just want okay it's like you know
it's like another chore they blew by out
jerk y'all from good do something else
it's like sometimes you think that other
hand now it's like I I gotta be I gotta
be honest with you it's it's it really
is [ __ ] ridiculous like the amount of
complain and women do the way a husband
is treated dude like I always say like
when you first meet your wife you're
like the starting quarterback on the
team and by the time you get [ __ ]
married you get treated like you're on
the taxi squad like like you never even
won a championship ever well that's
exactly right before like before you
have a kid like your Duke you're the
number one seed now my dog is like a
seven seed now my dog and now my dogs
like Wichita State I'm in the NIT dude
Alissa I get the kid comes first
that's not what I'm talking about is
like the the way somewhere along the
line you just start looking to yourself
like where did I become the PA of this
family
bill go grab us some coffees yeah I
don't I don't [ __ ] III you know that's
that's one of the I gotta be honest with
you dude all this [ __ ] moaning and
complaining that all these women are
doing specifically white women which is
just inherently hilarious is I really
just like III I don't even know where to
[ __ ] begin on this one because every
[ __ ] guy that I talked to who's
married is really in the same situation
and I think it's why guys are so funny
it's because our our situation is funny
it's like you're you're your status
versus they're complaining you would
think that they were living the way that
we're living it doesn't even it's like
you're living in like this alternate
universe like sometimes you want to be
like wait you're complaining you're
you're tired like I I don't know I I
just say I'm a terrible husband but my
wife doesn't really complain my wife is
not like I'm playing she's she's a she's
really gonna come back Jesus well they
you don't but you know but you're you're
a much better husband than me I'm sure
my wife has her complaints no no I'm not
even saying about wife you know I'm
talking about my my wife Elena I'm
talking about all this [ __ ]
complaining that is going on with women
right now and it's just like like when
they get [ __ ] married for the most
[ __ ] but it's like I'm trying to think
of a guy that I know who's actually even
remotely running his household I just
don't see I just don't see it it's like
what they want and if they don't get
what they want then you're gonna have to
deal with their emotions for three days
so you just like subconsciously you just
start giving into it okay which is how
the thing works which is fine so I don't
understand what all the [ __ ]
complaining is about but evidently
evidently because they only got the
right to vote a hundred years ago their
lives are [ __ ] horrific
girl do I get to bring up the potato
famine girl had kissed another guy oh
jesus here we go
hey I narrow broad hey Billy red nuts
I like how you want to use your new
[ __ ] I know it's great very broad I
think that's a great one I love it no
but that isn't she said she kissed
another guy so she wouldn't be well I
think she's like I can't sorry I know
you get that dyslexia yeah and I blend
them blind okay all the hate no yeah
you're gonna get it all and just another
guy all right
not non-binary Yeah right on the [ __ ]
we're on the edge of society no there's
other letters at the end of the LBG baby
what is that one queer nation gender
queer alright there's another one Bravo
sports feeders don't never remember it I
just want to say I have a lot of respect
for you and thank you anyways I'm a
freshman in college and I live on the
same Hall as my girlfriend the other
night a bunch of the people on our floor
were drinking we all got plastered one
thing leads to another and someone
proposes the idea of spin the bottle I'm
not stoked on playing but whatever I
guess alright there's your first mistake
you didn't validate what you were
feeling kissing a few dudes and some
girls that I don't want to kiss as
evidently how my night is gonna go well
you have to kiss the guys yeah that's
alright everything every time it's a
different world out there Jeff yeah
every time it lands on me I'm doing the
tight-lipped [ __ ] as to not upset anyone
because that light seemed like the right
thing to do wait so the guys kissed the
guys too which is crazy
my girlfriend however is straight-up
lip-locking kissing dudes no tongue or
passion or anything but still I felt
weird about it yeah later that night
pride to me yep so now you feel like the
[ __ ] and assured me that it didn't
mean anything but I just can't get the
image of her kissing this other do it
out of my head nor should you
she would never cheat on me I know that
so I'm probably just being a [ __ ] any
advice would be appreciated here's some
advice don't play spin-the-bottle with
the chickee have [ __ ] feelings with
with other guys there's gamers spin the
bottle ever hey here's my girlfriend and
some dudes you're always gonna come you
always going to lose you're always like
you're always at the bottom you win for
you
so if you find the one hot chick you
kind of like on that floor then your
girlfriend's gonna be pissed why would
you play that game
All Right see here's the thing dude I
can tell you this right now if it was
the other way around and she felt it she
would have cried either way and she
would have felt upset about it and you
you would have had to validate her
feelings on it okay but because now it's
all about their [ __ ] feelings here
I'm so [ __ ] JD dude it's gonna be all
about [ __ ] you dude this is what you
feel let her cry all the [ __ ] she wants
this is what you feel if you can't get
past it [ __ ] break up with her but
here's another thing - you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] up in the beginning okay this is
a life lessons you were not cool with it
and you didn't but you seem like a shut
down dude we're just like well I'm just
gonna go along with this even though I
don't like this so now you turn around
in a way you know something wait I
changed this because you acted like you
were okay with it and now you're not and
now you're judging her so now actually
you know something
you [ __ ] up here sir I'm just gonna
give it to you straight like a man you
didn't feel like you you weren't
comfortable with it and you didn't
[ __ ] say anything and then you sat
back and you let her do [ __ ] you weren't
comfortable with and now you're given
grief over it so now you know something
I actually validate her tears took me a
minute took me a while Joe I had to get
there I had to get there I validate her
tears and I will say this she's a chick
you're dating on your floor your
freshman year of college get over it
move along don't put too much into her
you're gonna live your whole life yeah
it's a bad thing ever the same floor
that's a bad situation anyway we you
know that's it's gonna go bad
enjoy the joy the moment you had move
along the sophomore year I try not to
date someone on your floor banger but
thumbs like a dater
I'm at stage advice Joe bartnik
everybody rose bowl tailgate legend
absolutely crushed it over here in
Europe and we're gonna go walk along the
boardwalk here around in Israel and
there the boardwalk down by the
Mediterranean Sea sorry I can't sing
alright go Bruins
wrap it up tonight I hope that's it and
thank you to everybody the bottom my
heart everybody who showed up ridiculous
amount of people showed up on this tour
I want to thank them too and I mean just
as the opening act you guys treated me
[ __ ] amazing
everybody loved Europe everybody yep and
we're gonna finish strong tonight here
in Tel Aviv thank you for the whole tour
man thank you and thank club soda Kenny
for treat me the best Kenny's the caddy
is the best he's a prince he's like the
Prince of Europe that's right
all right guys go [ __ ] yourselves I'll
talk to you on Thursday